das dschungelcamp wurde abgesagt was
kannst du uns da zu sagen was er hinter
den kulissen jetzt los ja wir haben hier
heute mittag bei bild live das erste mal
exklusiv darüber berichtet dass das
dschungelcamp 2021 nicht stattfinden
wird
ich sag mal so rtl war nicht besonders
erfreut darüber dass wir das heute
verkündigt haben denn rtl hatte ein
bisschen einen anderen plan
und durch unsere berichterstattung
wurden da hinter den kulissen wurde da
sehr sehr viel durcheinander geschmissen
und man kann sagen sie nach es ist ein
chaos protokoll eine ganz ganz kleine
einordnung wales hat ja ein lockdown
verkündet daraufhin hat man sich bei rtl
getroffen die entscheider haben sich
getroffen haben überlegt okay wie gehen
wir damit um
laut unseren informationen haben sie
sich entschieden das camp abzusagen
aber statt eine offizielle mitteilung
heraus zu geben wollte man erst so
unsere informanten die kandidaten
informieren nun ist das aber alles
trotzdem zu uns durchgesickert wir haben
dann natürlich bei rtl angefragt bei rtl
wusste man aber angeblich von nichts
und als dann unsere nachricht raus
gegangen ist dass das dschungelcamp
abgesagt wurde für dieses jahr hat man
bei punkt 12
alles dementiert und gesagt entgegen
aller medienberichte findet das
dschungelcamp statt um dann kurze zeit
später selber bei rtl auf der seite zu
verkünden dass das dschungelcamp sehr
wohl abgesagt wurde
aber es eine show gibt eine
dschungelshow
also man achte ganz genau darauf es wird
kein dschungelcamp geben sondern eine
dschungelshow und wie erklärst du dir
das ganze war erst jahren hier ist
wirklich abgesagt dann jetzt haben sie
doch zugegeben warum das ganze warum
nicht klar kommuniziert das ist ja auch
ein begrünter grund kroner macht uns
jetzt alle irgendwie einen strich durch
die rechnung das hätte man ja einfach
klar kommunizieren können das
dschungelcamp ist bei rtl ein ganz ganz
großes geheimnis da sind nicht viele
leute in die planung mit involviert und
auch nicht in die kommunikation
ich kann mir gut vorstellen dass viele
das selber noch gar nicht wussten weil
die entscheidung dass man das
camp ab sagt wurde ja auch relativ
kurzfristig erst gefällt
nun ist das natürlich was man hier jetzt
betreibt mit dem dementi und um dann zu
sagen der dschungel findet statt
es wird eine show das ist natürlich
wortklauberei am ende des tages stellt
corona die produktionsfirma und rtl für
eine vor ein sehr sehr großes problem
denn natürlich wie soll man mit einer
ganzen produktions mannschaft nach mail
wales fahren wie soll man die kandidaten
schützen gegebenenfalls gibt es
einreiseverbote dann nutzt vielleicht
jemand in quarantäne der aufwand ist
wahnsinnig groß dann gibt es ja noch das
problem dass man aber schon verträge
geschlossen hat man hat schon verträge
mit den kandidaten geschlossen also was
macht man jetzt wir haben ja schon mitte
september darüber berichtet dass es
mehrere szenarien gibt aufgrund von
corona das eine wäre australien das
wurde gecancelt dass die anderes
szenario wäre das schloss in wales
gewesen das wurde jetzt auch gecancelt
das dritte szenario wäre eine show aus
deutschland und wir haben mittlerweile
auch die information dass diese
dschungel show die rtl ja heute
bestätigt und angekündigt hat definitiv
in deutschland gedreht werden soll
die frage ist jetzt nur noch findet sie
mithalten kandidaten statt und man macht
eine art highlight show oder muss man
sich an die verträge halten und nimmt
die kandidaten die quasi jetzt unter
vertrag stehen das ist jetzt die grosse
frage und da wird natürlich hinter den
kulissen wahnsinnig rotiert weil mit
jedem management neu verhandelt werden
muss
jeder muss neu gefragt werden kannst du
dabei sein kannst du nicht dabei sein
oder verschieben wir das alles auf
nächstes jahr
und dann die große frage haben wir
corona nächstes jahr überstanden
also es ist ein krimi ein dschungel
krimi hinter den kulissen kann man so
schön sagen dankeschön dafür einen
exklusiven einblick und natürlich hast
du uns auch da auf dem laufenden halten
weitere da was man nur weil es
neuigkeiten gibt bin ich wieder hier
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren